john lennon as gollum a steamy romance
between frodo and galadriel it all could
have happened but you'll never get to
see it j.r.r tolkien's vast and beloved
legendarium has been portrayed on screen
many times over the years long before
the first successful attempt came to
fruition however many others had tried
their hands at adapting middle earth for
the movies but what did tolkien himself
think about all this well in 1968 the
telegraph published an interview with
the author in which he expanded on his
views regarding the rights to adapt his
world for the screen as it turned out
tolkien had been solicited countless
times by people hoping to put the middle
earth stamp on everything from movies
and tv shows to puzzles and soaps but
his fans at the time weren't exactly
supportive of these ideas the article
cites one 17 year old fan who wrote to
tolkien don't let them make a movie out
of your ring it would be like putting
disneyland into the grand canyon for his
part it seems that tolkien agreed albeit
for slightly different reasons he told
the telegraph you can't cramp narrative
into dramatic form it would be easier to
film the odyssey much less happens in it
only a few storms
oh come to this happy place
welcome
nowadays it seems like nearly every
major movie and television franchise in
existence falls under the jurisdiction
of the house of mouse everything from
the marvel cinematic universe to the
star wars galaxy to the muppets is owned
and controlled by disney and there was a
very brief period in which the company
considered staking a claim in middle
earth in 1938 just a year after the
hobbit was released a disney animator
suggested combining elements of the
novel with richard wagner's ring cycle
of musical dramas for a segment in the
animated movie fantasia disney also
tried and failed to produce a film of
the hobbit during the 1950s disney
animator wolfgang rytherman once claimed
that disney even considered adapting the
lord of the rings but decided it was too
long and unwieldy for the big screen
this may have been for the best however
because tolkien truly detested disney in
one of his letters written in 1937 the
author claimed he loathed the studio and
insisted any illustrations for an
american publication of the hobbit not
be influenced by disney's animations
tolkien echoed these sentiments in a
later letter written in 1968 in which he
wrote i recognize disney's talent but it
has always seemed to me hopelessly
corrupted though in most of the pictures
proceeding from his studios there are
admirable or charming passages the
effect of all of them to me is
disgusting tolkien's first positive
response to an attempted hollywood
adaptation of the lord of the rings came
in 1957. that year american sci-fi
editor forrest j ackerman and producer
al brodak teamed up with writer morton
grady zimmerman to approach the author
with their idea for an animated
middle-earth movie tolkien was initially
impressed by their illustrations which
he noted to be in the style of
celebrated literary illustrator arthur
rackham he was less impressed by the
proposed storyline however which
featured what he called a general
degradation of the story nevertheless
the rights were optioned to team
ackerman partly because tolkien believed
he could acquire an author's veto on
anything he didn't like soon after
zimmerman sent tolkien a detailed
treatment of his lord of the rings story
tolkien's response written to ackerman
in a letter was anything but approving
mostly he complained about zimmerman's
rampant carelessness with the narrative
but tolkien's greatest criticism had to
do with the tone which he believed was
too action-heavy and failed to
accurately represent the heart of the
tale in the end the ackermann project
died a pitiful death the project was
shut down after failing to fund his
request for an extension to the rights
the whole world was gripped by
beatlemania in the 1960s perhaps
inevitably the runaway success of the
fab four's music was accompanied by a
number of live-action films including a
hard day's night and help it was during
this period that the beatles attempted
to get a lord of the rings movie off the
ground john lennon in particular was a
fan of tolkien and believed that he and
his band mates could very well star in
the picture lennon as gollum paul
mccartney as frodo george harrison as
gandalf and ringo starr as sam they even
approached stanley kubrick who had just
directed 1964's dr strangelove to helm
the project gentlemen you can't fight in
here this is the war room
sadly it wasn't to be for one thing
kubrick wasn't interested but it appears
that tolkien himself drove the final
nail into the beatles coffin in 2021
peter jackson told the bbc that the
author himself had refused the fab four
permission to make their movie jackson
claimed he didn't like the idea of a pop
group doing his story the director added
what would the beatles have done with
the lord of the rings soundtrack album
that would have been 14 or 15 beatles
songs that would have been pretty
incredible to listen to
in 1969 united artists acquired the film
rights to the lord of the rings tolkien
was 77 years old by that point and had
decided that he would not live to see
his novel appear on screen as such he
didn't particularly care who ended up
with the rights a few years later united
artists hired director john borman to
helm a live-action adaptation of the
novel porman would later become renowned
for movies such as deliverance and hope
and glory but at that time he had
directed just a handful of features
screenwriter rosbo pallenberg worked
with foreman to figure out how best to
bring middle earth to life on the silver
screen he ended up writing a 176 page
script for their movie the details of
the screenplay range from fascinating to
mortifying it featured a kabuki style
theatrical performance of middle-earth's
history a love scene for frodo and
galadriel and a battle of words fought
between gandalf and saruman foreman's
film was destined to fail however united
artists ran out of money after a number
of commercial setbacks finally deciding
not to move forward with the project the
good news though is that the script
still exists online just in case you
want to better imagine a movie in which
aragorn and boromir passionately kiss
beekeepers defend the walls of menace
tirith and mary blinds a horse with a
frying pan
the title of ralph bakshi's animated
middle-earth movie the lord of the rings
is something of a misnomer as it only
tells the story of the fellowship of the
ring and certain aspects of the two
towers gandalf
beyond all
hope
upon its release in 1978 the lord of the
rings was a considerable financial
success earning 30 million dollars
worldwide off an estimated 4 million
budget but it was met with poor reviews
from fans who were not pleased at all
with what they considered to be subpar
visuals and the fact that the movie
ended halfway through the story part 2
of bakshi's tale was green lit for
release in 1980. initially the film's
creators were optimistic but a sequel to
the lord of the rings simply never
materialized screenwriter peter s beagle
later recalled that it all came down to
creative differences between bakshi and
producer saul zance bakshi in particular
believed that the first movie simply
hadn't been as good as it could have
been in 1980 the production company rank
and bass which had made 1977's animated
hobbit movie released the return of the
king as an abc television special while
this had nothing to do with bakshi's
half-completed project the story does
pick up around the same point that the
lord of the rings ended providing fans
with a kind of unofficial conclusion to
the 1978 movie
in the early 1990s russian director
roman mitrofenov set out to bring an
animated adaptation of the hobbit to
life but the project fell apart when the
soviet union crumbled in 1991. here's
the fun part though the movie's six
minute prologue depicting the fall of
erebor and dale still exists online the
sequence opens on a party in dale in
which the townsfolk cavort and dance in
the square enter smaug who destroys dale
and takes erebor for his own as the snow
falls the scene cuts to a meeting of the
dwarves and gandalf who suggests they
hire a burglar to accompany them on
their quest for vengeance you'll
probably know all this of course if
you've already seen or read the hobbit
but the metrophenol prologue features a
couple of interesting quirks not seen in
the novel that peter jackson appears to
have referenced in his movies for
example the people of dale fly dragon
kites just like they do in an unexpected
journey and while the animated airborne
looks much different to jackson's
version the sight of dale covered by
snow will look all too familiar to fans
of the latter now it is a ruin
the desolation of smog
you can only imagine how the hobbit
movies might have looked if mitrofenov
had finished his adaptation
a 2021 essay written for polygon by film
critic drew mcweeney tells the story of
the war between jackson and disgraced
producer harvey weinstein over the lord
of the rings movies having worked with
jackson on many of his previous films
weinstein acquired the rights to the
lord of the rings from saul's hands and
hired the director and his screenwriting
partners bran walsh and philippa boyens
to make it a reality the first outline
jackson and walsh prepared for miramax
weinstein's company told a story across
two pictures the fellowship of the ring
and the war of the ring mcweeney writes
that the original scripts felt like
watching the final movies at 1.5 times
the speed many characters get little
development the shire scenes are short
and the elves are met only briefly
weinstein wasn't exactly cooperative
during pre-production and eventually
restricted jackson to a measly 75
million dollar budget so jackson and
walsh decided on a desperate gamble to
save their movie they leaked the script
for their project to mcweeney who then
reviewed it on anicool news weinstein
pushed jackson even further after that
demanding the lord of the rings become
one four hour film jackson refused and
weinstein conceded giving up the movie
on the condition that miramax be repaid
everything that had already been spent
on development luckily new line execs
bob shay and michael deluca rode in to
save the day committing to the project
and insisting on three lord of the rings
movies the rest as they say is history
in a hole in the ground
they lived
a hobbit
in 2008 j.r.r tolkien and guillermo del
toro fans alike were overjoyed to learn
that the acclaimed fantasy slash horror
director had been hired to helm new line
cinema's hobbit movies they were
somewhat less overjoyed to learn two
years later that del toro had left the
project citing production delays and
other commitments as the reasons for his
departure for better or for worse the
hobbit trilogy would eventually be
directed by peter jackson so how would
del toro's middle earth saga have played
out well for one thing it was intended
to take place over the course of two
movies rather than three an unexpected
journey and there and back again in 2011
new yorker writer daniel zalewski
visited del toro's home and got a
glimpse at how the films may have looked
he described seeing a sketch of smog the
dragon that resembled a flying axe and
drawings of other new monsters such as
an armor-plated troll that could curl up
into a ball del toro also elaborated on
making middle earth look like a
psychedelic painting rather than the
realistic new zealand landscapes that
peter jackson eventually utilized of
course it's impossible to say whether
del toro's hobbit movies would have been
any better or worse than jackson's but
one thing is for sure they clearly would
have made for one heck of a trip
[Music]